[Musik]
hallo
ring ding so aufgeregt manuel ich auch
ich glaube wir sind jetzt live auf
youtube hallo leute komisch oder ich
podcaster sonst gerne ohne kamera aber
da ist auch viel bequemer aber muss man
sich nicht anziehen also keine formel
also sich nicht schick machen muss ich
duschen kann einfach aus dem bett
aufstehen
aber was machen weil ich nach 100
episoden
wir haben uns heute richtig vorbereitet
für euch liebe zuschauer ihr seht ihr
jetzt zum ersten mal wie das hier
aussieht bei uns es ist episode nummer
100 manuel wie sieht es denn bei dir aus
ist das der normale ort an dem du sonst
podcast hinein normalerweise podcast ich
in meinem schrank weil ich da einen
guten trockenen ton habe und heute bin
ich im wohnzimmer was noch etwas kahl
ist deswegen klinge ich heute vielleicht
ein wenig ruhiger echo ich gemerkt und
du ja ich bin an meinem normalen
schreibtisch aber normalerweise steht
der so nah und im hintergrund ist dann
das fenster das heißt man sieht mich
nicht so gut ich habe jetzt heute extra
nicht rein gemacht so schön licht
aufgestellt und ich habe meinen
kleiderschrank in den hintergrund
gemacht damit ich kein licht im
hintergrund a very nice - wir sind hier
voll youtube plus podcast profi was
feiern wir denn heute manuel ja episode
100 obwohl wir eigentlich schon viel
mehr episoden gemacht haben und das ist
auch eine gute überleitung denn ich habe
ich weiß du magst gerne quizze und ich
habe ein kleines quiz vorbereitet für
dich kari das finde ich toll
wir müssen aber erst mal die leute
begrüßen haben einige leute die schon zu
schauen ich weiß nicht genau wie viele
aber jetzt über 1000 leute zu der chat
ist am durchdrehen hallo leute ich
wollte euch gerade fragen woher er kommt
aber so schnell kann ich gar nicht lesen
wie ihr schreibt hallo aus georgien
indonesien houston usa tolles mikrofon
austria in nicaragua oder halo aus wie
einer mauer aus der ganzen welt gucken
uns leute zu sogar mitten in der nacht
waren sich in vietnam ist es doch jetzt
irgendwie ein uhr oder sonne
ja das ist toll kari apropos zahlen hier
kommt dass chris ich weiß nicht wie gut
warst du früher in mathe in der schule
sehr gut
wer grüßt okay das haben jetzt mal
testen also das hier ist unsere episode
100 aber streng genommen haben wir schon
jahrhundert 19 episoden gemacht ich
glaube das ist jetzt hier schon quasi
eigentlich episode 120 denn wir haben ja
zwischendurch diese zwischen dinger
gemacht diese kurzen zwischendurch
episoden bevor wir dann auf drei mal die
woche gewechselt sind und mit dieser
ganzen informationen darfst du jetzt mal
schätzen wie viel material also wenn
jemand heute anfangen würde bei episode
1 und durch hören würde bis episode 99
mit allen episoden dazwischen inklusive
zwischen dinger wie viele stunden und
minuten müsste sie hören das ist ganz
schön aufregend also am anfang haben wir
ungefähr eine stunde gepostet also ich
schätze mal die ersten 50 waren so eine
stunde dann haben wir schon mal 50
stunden
dann haben wir noch die zwischen dinge
und die anderen sachen wenn das dann
noch mal 70 sind mal 30 sind das
ungefähr 35 stunden sagen wir mal 90
stunden material nicht schlecht 76
stunden und 48 minuten das sind knapp
über drei tage die ich mir noch mal
selber dann haben wir ja irgendwann
angefangen noch so eine after show zu
machen
wer ab und zu noch so ein bonus am ende
posten für die mitglieder
was meinst du wie viel ist das
mittlerweile auch mal da ist ja immer
alles reiner ich habe die am anfang ich
mittlerweile höre ich die aftershow
immer und ich habe sogar gemerkt unsere
kathrins also unsere mitglieder hören
die auch immer bis zum ende
ja es ist schon manchmal zehn minuten 15
minuten auch manchmal mancher besprechen
wir unsere termine und dann haben wir
schon ein paar mal so einen test gemacht
um zu gucken ob die leute noch zu hören
während wir unsere termine besprechen
und haben sie tatsächlich sagen wir mal
sagen wir mal ungefähr pro episode 5 x
120 wir haben aber viel später erst
angefangen damit nicht sagen dass dieser
1 ja dann sagen wir mal zehn stunden
auch sehr gut geschätzt acht stunden
mittlerweile und jetzt kommt eine letzte
frage
ja denn wir haben zu allen episoden ein
transkript und was schätzt du wie viele
wörter sind das insgesamt mittlerweile
das habe ich nicht ganz genau
ausgerechnet aber ungefähr
du kannst es auch ausdrücken in büchern
oder in einem bekannten buch
wir rechnen also ist es mehr als ein
buch ja vielleicht auch das ist jetzt
schwierig weil ich lese noch gar keine
bücher
ok ich sag mal nutzer also soll ich mal
sagen sagt meine wörter zahlwörter zahl
also wie viele wörter sprechen wir denn
pro minute das sagen wir mal pro minute
sprechen wir schon mal 40 wörter mal 60
sind 2400 x 75 stunden
sag mal aus und auch 180 tausend wörter
also sind deutlich mehr es ist ungefähr
eine halbe million wörter oder ungefähr
so viel wie die gesamte herr der ringe
reihe ohne ja fast manuel was nicht
wundert ist dass ja mich noch gar nicht
vorbei gekommen ist wenn es was zu
feiern gibt ist ja immer dabei was hast
du denn zum feiern mitgebracht heute
wasser ich habe eine flasche sekt die
ist noch von meinen eltern die waren zu
besuch im eisfach haben wir nicht
geschafft und ich dachte ich mach dir
mal auf heute feiert das teil ist was
das is ja genial
damit habe ich nicht gerechnet gibt es
gibt ja was zu feiern und hast du denn
was mitgebracht vielleicht luftschlangen
nix tut mir leid
ja nichts sound machine feiern ja auf
100 episoden manuell auf 100 episoden
prost erleben wir jetzt ein großes
desaster wird jetzt gleich das
schlafzimmer voller schaum
hätte ich das ja post ist schluss mit
wasser an ich weiß das macht man nicht
in deutschland aber für dich so zu sagen
also ja nicht so als wärst du jetzt hier
und das bis jetzt auf den podcast und
auf dich manuel denn du hast dieses
projekt gestartet auf uns alle und auf
alle die zuhören und zuschauen
janosch man sich gar nicht wie geht's
dir denn heute nach 100 100 jahren
podcast freut er sich immer und manchmal
lacht er dann laut im nebenraum dass wir
mag es aussehe anderen münchen zu
erzählen wie toll ihr seid ja wir haben
seine freunde getroffen und ich habe
angefangen zu erzählen wie toll das auch
ein bisschen peinlich
jetzt auch sachen musik es ist aber gut
ja ja das ist eigentlich auch eine gute
überleitung denn wir haben uns überlegt
wir wollen heute mal also es ist
wirklich eine gute überleitung denn wir
wollten ja zumindest einmal kurz darüber
sprechen warum wir das hier überhaupt
machen oder das ok das ist unser
thema der woche jahrhundert episoden
warum machen wir das überhaupt garrido
dass anfang okay ich sage ganz ehrlich
also am anfang habe ich das ja einfach
so aus spaß ausprobiert du hattest bock
auf das projekt ich hatte gar keine
ahnung wie das funktioniert mit so einem
podcast aber ich dachte reden das kann
ich aber ich es ganz ehrlich meine
größte motivation ist und das sehe ich
auch bei youtube ist dass ganz viele
menschen deutsch lernen nach deutschland
kommen und dieser prozess des lernens
und des neu science ist ja auch manchmal
schwierig na also generell ist es schon
schwierig im leben mit manchen
änderungen klarzukommen ich merke dass
jetzt wieder im winter es wird dunkel
draußen jetzt haben wir noch corona dann
kommt so eine kleine wintermüdigkeit wo
man denkt auch man jetzt wieder sechs
monate warten und dann freue ich mich
besonders auf meine lieblingssendungen
auf meine podcast fernsehshows und das
macht mir dann gute laune und seine
laune braucht man auch wenn man in ein
neues land zieht man braucht irgendwie
freunde die einem helfen dabei und ich
hoffe dass wir so ein freund sind und
dass wir menschen ein bisschen dabei
helfen können die sprache zu lernen und
sich in deutschland ein bisschen wohler
zu fühlen weil hier ist es ja manchmal
kalt und dunkel und manchmal sind die
leute auch unfreundlich und ich hoffe
dass wir den leuten einfach ein bisschen
bessere laune machen können das ist
total schön und das wollte ich
eigentlich als letztes sagen aber da
schließe ich mich jetzt einfach an und
ich finde es auch sehr schön weil uns
oft leute schreiben so hey ihr kennt
mich nicht aber ich habe euch jetzt so
lange zugehört und habe so viele von
euch erfahren über diesen podcast das
dass es sich anfühlt als wärt ihr meine
freunde und auch wenn wir den ganzen
leuten natürlich nicht kann man hin zu
hören fühlt sich das so an als hätten
wir durch diesen podcast wahnsinnig
viele freunde einfach gewonnen auf der
ganzen welt und das klingt vielleicht
ein bisschen sentimental weiß ich nicht
aber das ist für mich auch eine ganz
große freude
ansonsten hoffe ich also müssen wir von
anfang an war meine hoffnung dass wir es
irgendwie schaffen einen weg zu finden
die leute deutsch lernen können entweder
ganz aktiv und so selbst motiviert
richtig mit hinsetzen und transkript
lesen und wörter unterstreichen und also
aktives lernen aber eben auch so dieses
passive ich höre einfach zu und ab und
zu hole ich mal das handy aus der tasche
und guck auf dem wort oder ab und zu
schlag ich mal was nach aber ich umgebe
mich einfach passiv mit der sprache und
das war meine hoffnung und ich glaube
das funktioniert ja ganz gut und das
dann eben so zu machen dass es
entertaining genug ist also irgendwie
spannend und unterhaltsam genug dass man
auch noch weiter hört wenn man schon
sehr gut deutsch spricht weil das habe
ich immer bei mir selbst gemerkt dass
ich so manche sachen mehr angehört habe
zum sprachenlernen die ich dann
aufgehört habt zu hören als ich die
sprache schon gut genug konnte und das
ist meine hoffnung dass wir das noch
sehr lange zeit bieten können danke
manuel für deine ansprache ist gibt es
von meiner seite ein lautstarker gesagt
ja was machen wir jetzt mal ich bin ganz
aufgeregt ja ich meine das ist ja jetzt
ist wäre jetzt eine eine gute
gelegenheit wo wir schon so viele leute
haben die hier dabei sind dass wir
einfach mal wieder unser bekanntes
segment machen hält dem schönen namen
ist schon bereit
eure fragen
jetzt wird es tatsächlich etwas
schwierig wir wollen eure fragen live
hier beantworten allerdings ist der chat
so schnell dass wir und easy easy ist im
cic und managt den chat oder versucht
auch ein bisschen zu moderieren
sie soll die fragen raussuchen aber es
ist so schnell dass wir kaum was lesen
können also wir würden euch gerne jetzt
bitten schreibt uns fragen die wir
beantworten können hier im chat aber
nicht ganz so viel gleichzeitig recht
euch abbitte einer nach dem anderen
aber ja dass wir freuen uns auf eure
frank ich habe schon eine einstiegsfrage
und zwar hat die natalia auf bachelor
gepostet und damit wollte ich mal
angefangen das finde ich nämlich
persönlich sehr interessant sie schreibt
seid ihr introvertiert oder
extrovertiert you das angehängte frage
also ich glaube ich bin schon
extrovertiert weil ich gerne auf leute
zugehen und gerne weiß ich nicht ich bin
schon extrovertiert aber ich hab da so
ein bestimmtes limit also ich kann nur
eine zeitlang extrovertiert sein und
danach brauche ich ganz viel zeit für
mich selbst aber ich glaube wenn wir das
nur in diesem wärme witzigerweise gerade
viel über labels gesprochen und
kategorien
und ich habe auch ein label benutzt und
viel feedback bekommen dass das kein
gutes label ist genau und deswegen ja
aber wenn ich mich entscheiden müsste
würde ich sagen ich bin extrovertiert
und genieße es zeit für mich selbst zu
haben ja ich muss sagen es gibt ja
häufig ein missverständnis zwischen
extrovertiert sind leute die gerne viel
reden und introvertiert sind leute die
gerne wenig reden und es ist ja aber
auch so dass es darum geht was dir gut
tut so extrovertiert heißt ja auch dass
du leute um dich herum brauchst haben
sich gut zu fühlen introvertiert heißt
er dass du viel ruhe braucht um sich gut
zu fühlen
und bei den gängigen persönlichkeitstest
sie man so machen kann bin ich
tatsächlich in der mitte ich bin sechs
prozent extrovertiert 40 introvertiert
und das heißt bei mir ich brauche immer
leute jede woche wenn ich zum beispiel
sieben tage keine mensch kein menschen
sehe dann fühle ich mich als wäre ich
nicht vollständig so ich brauche dann
den menschen in kontakt und ich gut zu
fühlen und auch irgendwie aufzugehen und
rolle zu haben
wenn ich jedoch jeden abend menschen
sehe dann habe ich nicht genug ruhe also
ich muss tatsächlich und ich habe mir
selber eine regel gemacht meine regel
ist drei tage die woche will ich abends
rausgehen oder leute treffen das ist
natürlich jetzt mit der korona situation
schwierig aber dann verabrede ich mich
zum beispiel zum spielen oder zum
telefonieren und vier tage die woche bin
ich zu hause das ist so ungefähr mein
maß na ja interessant ich glaube nach
dieser maßgabe bin ich sogar noch ein
bisschen weniger extrovertiert als du
klein warst der woche
dann haben wir einige andere fragen
bekommen oder möchtest du dir eine erste
frage aussuchen
sehr gerne vielen dank an die isu dass
du das so ein bisschen sortiert hier und
ich fange mal an mit einer einfachen
frage was sind eure lieblingslieder wo
das werk gilt bei mir sehr oft aber eins
meiner absoluten lieblingslieder seit
einigen jahren ist percy von glen
hansard ich könnte gar nicht ein
lieblingslied so schnell benennen
aber ich kann eine lieblingsband in
meine absolute lieblingsband heißt tango
tango
naja die fans sie hat sicherlich schon
geschickt schon öfter bei dir auch
gehört und ich war mal mit easy auf dem
konzert liebe easy die hörte er zu und
ließ gerade den chat das war so schön
und wenn wir das noch mal wiederholen
könnten
nach der korona pandemie das wäre mein
größter wunsch
ok dann besann dran
genau ich meine nächste frage ist von
aruna
weiß jemand von euch aus welcher region
manuels und carice deutsche aussprache
kommt manuel seine aussprache ist sehr
genau und sehr deutlich woher kommst du
das kommt von dem harten training das
sich deutlich sprechen soll
nein wir sind beide in münster in
westfalen geboren das ist in
westdeutschland in oder man sollte sagen
im westen von deutschland in der nähe
von den niederlanden und da spricht man
so wie wir sprechen richtig also relativ
keinen starken akzent oder keinen
starken dialekt kann man sagen
man redet überhaupt in norddeutschland
sehr viel hochdeutsch
was ist deine nächste lieblingsfrage
louis fragt was ist das schwierigste
wenn wir den podcast produzieren podcast
produzieren also ich würde sagen dass
zeit aufwendigste wo wir auch
mittlerweile einiges an hilfe haben ist
das transkribieren für das transkript
und die vokabeln aufzubereiten zum
lernen und vom das portal podcasten
selbst finde ich am schwierigsten
dass wir uns kurz fassen weil manchmal
können wir ewig lange reden
das stimmt das ist manchmal stressig
aber war nach links daniel schreibt
hallo mallorca wie ich habe noch eine
frage sag ich mal sonst du dich gerne
nackt wie viele deutsche so wäre
interessant über dieses thema zu reden
das ist ein interessantes thema
die deutsche fkk kultur rein
körperkultur viele leute denken ja dass
das alle deutschen so machen mangel was
du schon mal im fkk strand nicht dass
ich wüsste ich bin aber generell kein
strand über sicherheits immer nur so
zwei stunden aus und ich bin nicht so
ein strand typ tatsächlich oder legst du
manchmal nackt auf dem balkon auch ist
mit halt in worms
da gab es ja dieses berühmte bild von
dem typen der am teufelssee diese sache
also sehr wild das wildschwein verfolgt
hat nackt weil das wildschwein seinen
laptop geklaut hat es ist ein deutsches
ding aber man muss sagen es ist auch in
deutschland eine eigene kultur also es
gibt ja wie in allen ländern gibt es
verschiedene gruppen verschiedene
kulturen und nicht alle menschen in
deutschland machen dass oder sind daran
gewöhnt und manche familien sind so
aufgewachsen dass sie immer nackt am
strand sind und andere familien sind sie
aufgewachsen dass sie ihre kleidung
tragen und für mich ist es zum beispiel
so dass ich nirgendwo nackt war und
deswegen finde ich das auch komisch aber
ich weiß dass das gibt und ich weiß dass
viele leute teufel und es ist ein
interessantes phänomen ja spannend du
hast die frage übrigens nicht
beantwortet habe doch gesagt ich mache
das auch okay familie wurde das nicht
gemacht
okay gut ja als du ein kind warst fragt
dran wenn ich das richtig sehe was
wolltet ihr beruflich machen als ihr
kinder war spannend ich habe ich habe
noch eine liste von damals ja du auch
habe ich irgendwann wieder gefunden
also ich weiß dass ich zur
grundschullehrerin mal gesagt habe dass
ich gerne arbeitslos sein möchte ich
glaube ich war damals nicht so motiviert
ich weiß aber dass ich früh angefangen
habe auch durch jannis videos zu machen
und meine mutter hat auch sehr früh eine
videokamera gehabt damit habe ich viel
gefilmt also eigentlich habe ich schon
sehr lange medien gemacht interessant
das war tatsächlich nicht mein wunsch
also ganz früher als kind hatte ich
aufgeschrieben glaube ich pilotin wollte
ich auch mal machen ging aber nicht
wegen rot grün schwäche pilotin und
formel 1 fahren also auf jeden fall was
mit action wo ich am steuer sitze
aber ich dran hat noch geschrieben was
wäre wenn ihr keine videos produzieren
würde da nur noch podcast
zehn tage die woche schön matt hat
geschrieben das finde ich sehr
interessant was ist für euch der
schwierigste englische akzent zum
verstehen
krumme aus den usa und bin neugierig was
die deutschen darüber denken welche
akzente kannst du nicht gut verstehen
britisch-australische dann geht es noch
ganz nah gibt's noch den usa gibt es
ganz viele verschiedene akzente
ich würde mal so sagen so schottisch und
sonne stimmt oder vielleicht auch ich
war mal in der karibik so auf ich weiß
gar nicht mehr wo das war ja als ich in
mexiko beglichen auf meinen schritt und
dort wird zum teil englisch gesprochen
mit einem akzent der sehr sehr schwierig
ist zu verstehen das ist dann ja
teilweise schon eine kreol sprache wenn
es aus dem englischen entstanden ist
aber auch andere wörter aus anderen
sprachen hat ja ich finde da habe ich
auch schottisch schottisch und irisch am
schwierigsten
ich weiß dass ich mal mit jemandem aus
kansas city in einem hostel war und dass
ich da sehr schwer sieht das sehr schwer
von den zu verstehen ich glaube sonst in
den usa verstehe ich verstehe amerikaner
generell besser als briten und
australier habe ich letztens zum ersten
mal gemerkt hören sich für mich auch an
wie briten
ich habe nämlich eine serie geguckt auf
netflix und erst nach zwei staffeln
gemerkt dass die gar nicht in
großbritannien sondern in australien
spielt muss ausmachten kari raphael
möchte gerne ein bewerbungs interview
mit uns machen scheinbar und fragt wo
seht ihr euch in fünf jahren mal
anfangen
an der spitze der youtube charts und der
deutschen pop chaos könne keine ahnung
also ich bin totaler fan von short term
golf so kurzfristige ziele wo man sich
voll darauf fokussiert und immer so ein
jahr vielleicht in die zukunft gucken
und ansonsten einfach vertrauen da
das ist schon alles funktionieren wird
ich habe wirklich kein ziel so in fünf
jahren durch gerne sein möchte muss ich
sagen habe ich auch nicht so direkt also
ich möchte gerne dass sich unser projekt
entwickelt ich würde mich freuen wenn es
easy languages in allen sprachen gäbe
wenn wir auch so seltene sprachen oder
kleinere sprachen vielleicht produzieren
würden das wird mich auch freuen wenn
wir einfach mehr partner hätten aber ich
habe jetzt kein ziel ich möchte auf
jeden fall für mich selber persönlich
möchte ich dass ich mich
weiterentwickelt habe dass ich gelernt
habe wenn ich zurückblicke dass ich sehe
ich bin nicht mehr die carrer von vor
fünf jahren wäre ich glaube das wird
schon passieren
wichtige frage von hirsch in the woods
habt ihr auch im echten leben immer so
gute laune wie macht ihr das
also ich muss wirklich sagen caritas
bewundere ich auch an dir das finde ich
ist auch eine gewisse professionalität
dass du sagen kannst jetzt sind wir auf
sendungen und jetzt bin ich auch gut
drauf also ich weiß wir hatten so ein
paar momente zum beispiel am anfang des
podcasts wo wir mal eine stunde
aufgenommen haben und dann gab es ein
technisches problem und dann war die
stunde einfach weg und dann war die
stimmung erst mal so ziemlich down und
dann hast du gesagt so genau
und dann hast du gesagt wir machen uns
jetzt aber gute laune und wir starten
jetzt noch mal durch hast du das nicht
gesagt ich meine du du wärst das gewesen
aber jedenfalls nee also ich also ich
persönlich habe auch schlechte tage ich
weiß nicht wie es dir geht
okay was diejenigen die nicht auf
youtube schauen sondern das später im
podcast return jetzt nicht gesehen haben
ist das karree pantomime macht richtig
ich bin ein phantom ii meister
ja ich habe nicht immer so gute laune
muss ich sagen heute hatte ich auch mal
schlechte laune werk heute sogar heute
hatte ich schlechte laune
aber ich muss sagen dass ich das immer
ändern muss also wenn ich irgendwo
schlechte laune sehe bei anderen
menschen oder bei mir ich kann das so
nicht so lange aushalten ich will gerne
will dann gerne weitermachen will gerne
darüber reden bis wir das problem gelöst
haben und gute laune ist für mich das
gehört zum programm und das ist auch für
mich der sinn dieser show ja die frage
interessiert mich wie schreibt man hat
wer wird millionär dich als person
verändert
oh das weiß ich das müsstest du ja sagen
habe ich mich verändert seit wer wird
millionär ich glaube nicht
du hast jetzt bisher nicht so viele
sachen nee du hast mit deinem reichtum
nicht um dich geschmissen und das
gezeigt ich habe mir ein fernseher
gekauft das ist mein erster fernseher in
meinem leben das ist schon ein großer
und ja gut eine couch auch nach ich
hoffe nicht denn wenn geld ein sehr
verändert dann ist es ja schade meistens
also ich hoffe dass das die sängerin
mich nicht verändert hat kann ich auch
nicht bestätigen mein vorschlag wäre wir
beantworten noch zwei fragen ja und dann
damit ist jetzt aber schwierig da willst
du noch mehr machen lasst uns noch ja
wir gucken mal vielleicht noch nur
lightning around und notfalls schneiden
wir später ein bisschen für die die
nicht live dabei sind das ist dann ja
dann haben wir noch hier al hamsa
schreibt warum macht ihr den podcast
nicht auf englisch wie sie sagt dazu
hintergrund es gibt bald auch den
podcast in anderen sprachen zum beispiel
bei easy englisch wenn ihr englisch
lernen wollt geht mal zu easy englisch
bei youtube und hoffentlich bald auch
als podcast
da freue ich mich schon drauf eventuell
auch von anderen sprachen
kari welcher eigenschaft hättest du
gerne gerade ein freund an so sehr geht
ran klar was ist schwierig das hier sehr
persönlich nur wegen eigenschaft oder
soll ich mal was irgend etwas
also ich wäre natürlich gerne manchmal
noch ein bisschen und emotionaler
ich bin nämlich sachen sehr emotional
auf und ich möchte gerne noch besser
sein so im vermitteln dass es da ist es
mal gut wenn man und emotional ist
ansonsten wäre natürlich auch coolen
eigenschaft sowie in die zukunft gucken
wäre hilfreich
ich merke auch gerade dass wir das schon
mal darüber gesprochen haben ja dieser
wie jetzt gerade ja ich weiß allerdings
nicht mehr was ich damals gesagt hab
aber ich würde auch nicht gerne weniger
emotional sein aber die eigenschaft
entwickeln oder die fähigkeit entwickeln
meine emotionen noch besser von außen zu
beobachten also zu merken oder jetzt bin
ich gerade traurig oder glücklich oder
genervt oder was auch immer
aber da arbeite ich schon drin ja zum
beispiel das ist eines der ziele eine 1
1 der ziele von meditation kari würdest
du dich als ordentlich oder unordentlich
bezeichnen fragt traden sehr ordentlich
also er ordentlich was manchmal sagen
aber jetzt in der wohnung merke ich doch
schon in der neuen wohnung ich bin eher
ordentlich hanisch ist eher das
gegenteil du bist auch er ordentlich
würde ich einmal so einfach von dir
behaupten sehr ordentlich und ich finde
das ist immer ein sehr interessanter
kultur clash wenn jahre standen also
jetzt zum beispiel letztens mal umzug
näher als wir den keller ausmisten
mussten
das sind schöner satz den keller
ausmisten mussten also wir wollten die
alten sachen wegschmeißen
janisch mag es alles zu sammeln und ich
mag es einfach das alles das ist nicht
so viel gibt und alles gut geordnet ist
ja geht mir genauso ich mag es gerne
ordentlich und sauber
das ist eine frage die da aber schon mal
gesprochen wie bist du eigentlich auf
die idee gekommen mit dem podcast haben
wir das haben wir wahrscheinlich ganz am
anfang mal besprochen müsste den podcast
noch mal von vorn hören ich weiß das ist
es ich glaube ich höre es schon seit so
vielen jahren podcast dass ich
irgendwann immer dachte ich möchte
mitmachen und dann bei easyjet dachte
ich einfach irgendwie dass das könnte
doch hilfreich sein es gab nicht so
einen moment aber ich weiß dass ich
lange darüber geredet habe bis wir es
dann endlich gemacht haben
naja was fragt was ist unsere lieblings
episode von podcast hast du eine ich
hatte immer eine rede zunächst vergessen
wenn man nicht direkt darauf kommt ist
das schwierig janisch sagt immer die
episode mit der sound machine ist die
beste deswegen hat mich die leute
gebracht weil ja da hast ich weiß gar
nicht ob ich so ich glaube ich habe
manchmal so episoden wo ich denke also
die die es irgendwie nicht so gut
geworden aber ganz auf denke ich sah
dass die dati war und die episode daher
haben wir es geschafft eine gute balance
zu finden zwischen weiß ich nicht es hat
spaß gemacht wir waren gut drauf und wir
haben trotzdem auch irgendetwas
vermittelt oder über irgendein thema
gesprochen
das muss eine gute mischung sein auswahl
an und lernen und auch ernst nehmen wir
haben ja manchmal immer eine gute
mischung aus ernsten themen manchmal zu
viel ernst ich ernste themen manchmal zu
viel nicht zu verfangen kann es nicht
geben
apropos fans am wir ja nicht noch mal
zum ende ein laden für die auf diese
formale jannasch falls uns gerade
zuhörer ist hier live bei youtube.com
mal vorbei hier steht die tür offen für
dich wir freuen uns wenn du wieder
auftaucht
ist jetzt so ein test ob er überhaupt
noch zuhört ich suche mal eine gute
frage für ihn ja also hier geht's auf
jeden fall uns gitarre spielen das wird
ja noch interessieren ja sind gar nicht
mehr so viele fragen die wir haben aber
im live-chat da geht es rund runde
kowski viele fragen hier dabei oh ja das
kann man gar nicht sehr schnell
ja ich glaube er hat abgeschaltet
janosch ich rufe ich beantworte
währenddessen noch nachfrage hier fragt
jemand dass ich mal gesagt habe dass ich
minimalist bin und das erklären soll
ich glaube das ist wirklich eine gute
frage weil ich glaube nämlich
mittlerweile bin ich vielleicht nicht
mehr so minimalistisch wie früher als
ich nur einen rucksack hatte mit sachen
und damit auf weltreise war aber ja
jedenfalls finde ich es minimalistisch
wenn man nur die sachen hat die einem
wirklich freude bringen oder die man
wirklich haben will das ist schwer zu
erklären aber das heißt nicht dass man
nicht auch mehr haben kann als das was
man zum überleben braucht aber eben
nicht dinge anhäufen wo man sich
irgendwann fragt warum habe ich das
eigentlich
apropos geld da kommt jetzt eine frage
ganz wichtig du warst auf weltreise was
kostet das eigentlich wollte ich schon
sehr lange meinem blog post zu schreiben
wie ich nicht zu bekommen
es kommt sehr darauf an wie man reist
und so weiter aber es gibt ein gutes
buch das heißt heute travel world of
dollars the third day und das ist ein
ganz guter richtwert also man kann
relativ komfortabel reisen für 50 dollar
am tag wenn man flexibel ist und eine
gute mischung hat aus nicht so teuren
ländern und sehr teuren ländern mit
allem
mit allen ausgaben die man so hat ja
inkludiert das dann zählt
dafür muss man nichts halten ich glaube
da da kann man schon in einem bett
schlafen wenn viele nicht schlecht ja
dann haben wir hier noch eine frage von
zach er möchte wissen er weiß dass
janisch gerne gitarre spielt und aber
fragt ob auch andere von uns ein
instrument spielen und wenn wir eine
easy german band hätten wer würde was
spielen ja das ist eine gute frage was
würdest du dein spielen kann
ich würde gerne ich kann das aber nicht
ich würde gerne schlagzeugspielen es
leider schon besetzt von mir dann nehme
ich die synthesizer
sie schreibt man rein was du machen sie
was würdest du spielen würdest wie die
idee würde vielleicht will sie die bass
gitarre spielen also einer muss ja auch
noch singen
das wäre auch wer sind also easy
schreibt sie möchte ukulele spielen das
wird eine gute band schlagzeug bass
gitarre ukulele und kein sänger möchtest
du zum abschied noch mal und etwas
unseren zuschauern fragen sagen du
siehst das ist der chat mit unseren
antworten wir gucken gerade mal hier auf
youtube 1007 leute gucken zu
was ist deine nachricht wenn du jetzt
eine eine nachricht an die welt geben
kannst
er hat so viel spaß im leben wie es nur
geht
ja ja das waren jannis weise worte zum
abschied im podcast noch weitere worte
gibt es dann demnächst wieder bei
janosch philosophiert von ihnen fahre
ich freue mich auf weitere 10.000
episoden 100 wäre ja viel zu wenig die
haben wir schon in ein paar wochen
wo kommt diese episode eigentlich als
podcast raus kommt man an das transkript
genau gute fragen also vielleicht hören
uns ja leute zu die noch gar nicht den
podcast so regulär abonniert haben also
ein podcast findet man in jeder podcast
app da könnt ihr euch eine app aussuchen
und alle infos gibt es auch auf unserer
webseite the german punkt fm und unsere
mitglieder auf pages
die bekommen zu jeder episode ein
transkript und eine vokabel hilfe wo man
dann die wörter mit übersetzungen sieht
und bonusmaterial
genau das wäre noch nicht so die
wichtigsten punkte an und ich
tatsächlich eure nachrichten ich zeige
dass jetzt nicht andere aus
datenschutzgründen aber ich habe gerade
und natürlich aus licht gründen wie man
sieht ja ich habe gerade ich bekomme
hier die ganze zeit live updates aus
patchen was die leute schreiben ja ein
riegel hat zum beispiel gerade geschehen
auch eine frage geschickt auf bachelor
und schreibt liebe grüße aus brasilien
ihr seid super ich möchte gerne wissen
was denkt ihr über manfred mai über den
wolken es tatsächlich einen song den ich
gespielt wie hast du denn reinhard mey
heißt dahin gibt es glaube ich nicht
über den wolken ist auf jeden fall ein
bekannter klassischer soll in
deutschland den ich schon geschrieben
habe nicht geschrieben gespielt ja ich
hab ihn selber geschrieben wird 10
habe ich gespielt als wir so 10 12 jahre
alt waren da hatten wir nämlich eine
band easy an unsere freundin nachbarin
herne und ich weiß nicht ob sie sich
noch erinnert aber wir haben diesen song
gespielt und es war ziemlich tief über
den wolken und dann haben die anderen im
hintergrund gesungen jaja reinhard mey
ist ein toller liedermacher auch über
diese diesem song hinaus haben wir auch
letztens schon mal einen empfohlen im
podcast
es ist reinhard h h
so schnell geht das ihr werdet direkt
berichtigt von uns als betteln seid ihr
direkt live dabei und wir freuen uns auf
jeden fall wenn ihr ein mitglied werdet
denn dann macht ihr diesen podcast
tatsächlich auch möglich und bekommt
jede woche neue jede episode alle drei
tage alle zwei tage ein transkript auch
zu der episode manuels hat mich sehr
gefreut ich finde es toll wie wir heute
hier gefeiert haben marca schreibt noch
grüße aus pankow ich wohne um die ecke
von eurem büro und habe euch beim
vorbeigehen entdeckt so klein ist die
welt so kleines berlin ja schön also wir
hören uns bald wieder im podcast und
vielleicht bald mal wieder in einem
livestream obwohl das ganz schön
aufregend war das bald